Maurice jones-drew NFL Network analyst
the Rams radio color analyst as well and
his Twitter is at mjd mojo how are you
this morning yesterday though like I'm
not there it's okay
were you ever late for a meeting in your
career No how bad is it if you are I
mean you just get fined and too late you
know to make it a habit but to me is
unprofessional and I said I was going to
be there and I'm a man of my word so I
had a busy weekend and overslept a
little bit so it's okay there's one of
those things you have been there to
answer the bell many many many times on
this program so thank you for
apologizing but you didn't need to we're
talking about Kyler Murray here and I've
been saying I just want to know one
question if I'm an NFL team where I'm
the Oakland A's tell me what you love to
play and if you got to be all-in on
whatever that is but right now we don't
know where do you think Kyler Murray
ends up playing baseball or the NFL he's
a really good baseball player but you
know I think footballs are doing that he
didn't think he would have an
opportunity to play in the NFL and you
know the league is kind of changing a
little bit we don't need to be six five
six four six three to play quarterback
if you have skills the people you know
find ways to utilize you and tools to
their advantage and so we sit down with
a bar jack and saying that with some
other guys well Russell Wilson in a
shorter guy but the key can play and
that's in the gate and then the day
we're in the business of winning games
and he was a winner when I was in high
school he was a winner in college so I
know it's kind of hard to say that he
won't wait in NFL but I think there's
you know there are so many teams that
are looking for quarter
there's not going to be enough guys out
to those you see to go up and grab and
double whatever try to get up there
whatever it may be and find a way to get
them and see what happens
yeah I would be all-in if if I needed a
quarterback and needed but I don't know
you know the right situation for him
like the Giants need a quarterback I
don't think that they would draft Kyler
Murray Jacksonville needs a quarterback
but I don't know if they would draft
Kyler Murray Denver needs a quarterback
John Elway a former two sports star you
know would they bring him in to run that
kind of offense he got it it has to be
the right fit for him with the right
head coach right offensive coordinator
but I wonder if he finds out that the
consensus is he's a second-round pick in
the NFL mojo does that change how he
views baseball and football I personally
I wouldn't because the the second-round
pick is it's a beautiful thing stressing
out the new CBA you'll have to play
three years we can get your second deal
you can hit the band you can get to the
bank a little bit faster than obviously
guys in the first knowledge that are in
the first problem because they have a
fifty-year option so if he if he
believes in his ability and and he does
go to a team that thinks that they can
you can use them and then they kind of
build it around them similar so the
Cleveland Browns built around Baker
Mayfield this year um
I think you can have a lot of success
you know he's a very very talented
athlete with a great arm when he's
accurate and so that being said I mean I
get it you know I'm gonna be a little
biased because he's on the shorter side
but I think that if you can find ways to
get him going and get him comfortable
you would have a guy that can you know
can be similar to Doug Flutie that can
change the game we're talking to Maurice
jones-drew he's the analyst for the NFL
Network former running back and he does
the color commentary for the rams Radio
Network speaking of the Rams
more important work for their offensive
line or defensive line to be great
against New Orleans
ooh I'm gonna have to say defensive
lines you'd have to find ways to stop
throwing they did a great job against
the Dallas Cowboys stopping the runs you
have to do that again I mean also you
have to you have to get to Drew Brees
and you saw Philadelphia doing a really
good job of affecting Drew Brees and
both the coverage and and with the rush
and so you have to be able to try to do
some of those things and see if it works
out the offensive line
I think they late they had successful
last time they played but defensively I
just didn't get to Drew Brees and you
know we just don't know how that game
win so going down into New Orleans you
want to make sure to take that crowd out
I was similar to what Philly theater
earlier in the game and try to put up
points and you know what you're gonna
plan it w have to outscore in the
Warrens you can't you know expect to
keep them under 10 points or under 15
points for 14 points you gotta try to
score and beat him in the high 20s high
thirty so to me as the defensive line
getting pressure on Drew Brees and
forcing them without the ball in the
coverage and I love the Rams running
back situation you got a superstar and
girly and then a guy you got off the
couch and CJ Anderson
how does CJ Anderson come in and do what
he did in that game against a really
good run defense well CJ is a pro's Pro
and I think we would kind of take take
for what he's done for granted he's
undrafted guy but when Denver won their
Super Bowl let's remember Peyton Manning
was is the best ya year he was banged up
couldn't really throw it as much as he
wanted to and so they they ran the ball
you know Gary Kubiak who is now his name
go around and FA just silent Minnesota
but they ran the ball and they play
great defense and so it was really
interesting to see the way the the Rams
weren't about it being able to score 30
points without throwing a touchdown pass
which is huge so now we're showing you a
look we can run the ball to the best of
what we can do certain things and play
well and what really happens is he's
been the system before because McKay is
a is out of the Shanahan free
Gary Kubiak is out of the Shannon
Hanahan tree so it's probably similar
terminology get him a come in he's
comfortable he learned really quickly
the offense or we saw that the first
game he played but now you have two guys
who are completely different in style
you have Todd Gurley yeah like you said
the superstar speed puts his foot in the
ground to make you miss then you have
this guy that comes in and C they
intercept back it's gonna be a butter
but we'd like to call it better rugged
running back who's gonna run down he'll
try to run you over and so when you have
two knives who can run the same scheme
with different running styles it's hard
on defenses to try to tackle it and get
prepared and you saw the seed answer war
that defends down then Tigers able to
hit a couple big runs and that two guys
over 100 okay
yeah CJ will join us coming up next hour
the Patriots are gonna play up this
underdog oh woe is me
nobody thinks were any good and as I've
pointed out to this audience New England
was favored at home against a charger
team that came in with momentum and 12
and 4 on the year if you're Kansas City
are you viewing the Patriots as this
underdog or again so I don't know how
they can say that thing I was the only
one on our on our game day morning shut
up take two Chargers anyone else take
the Patriots and so yeah I get it you
know a couple people said you guys you
know kind of backed into the number to
see he didn't and all these things and
you gotta have some momentum and gotta
have something that they wake up in the
morning and get that extra set or wrap
it in in the weight room and make you
want to study a little harder let me say
this I'll say this this is important
because home-field advantage has been a
huge huge advantage here in the playoffs
and throughout the season the Patriots
on play that well on the road so I think
because it's the playoffs I think the
Patriots absolutely different applause
they are in the regular season
but that is something that that you have
to look at because we dolls
was a completely different team on the
world they were at home so they see if
they're able to kind of get around that
they've been on the road and find a way
to go and going to Kansas City's
supposed to be cold it's like a Patriots
like and they can play it their type of
football and you know these other things
but underdog wrong I don't think you got
the goat right can't be other driver to
the greatest of all time now let me go
back to the Cowboys game since you got
to see it firsthand with the Rams it
feels like that offense hasn't evolved
mojo and I it just doesn't feel like
it's 2019 what do you think of that
although I'll say they were they're very
creative in certain situations but it's
hard to kind of change your offense when
you get a dynamic player like a bard
Cooper in the middle this no I think you
see in the offseason that Scott Linehan
is gonna kind of look around the week
see what other people are doing Michael
down came open you know he kind of came
up big and he's in his last couple games
so he starts making plays about okay we
have two receivers now running back
tight in and then we'll open it up the
other thing is to their catering to the
quarterback and their quarterback guys
are really good he's really good with
he's running around with the ball on his
hands and he can run I can't do those
type of things so and I kind of I kind
of do you know like a relationship but
not all relationships the same but if it
works for you what David has is offense
so be it utilize it and try to be the
best you could be i think the baltimore
ravens show that as well that they were
able to run i don't know what we'd call
it a read option off it's a triple
option officer or i call it and make it
to the playoffs because it was different
and so how can dallas
you know get creative finding ways to
get back comfortable in the pocket throw
the ball but also all the ads running
the ball and getting the ball down the
field so Maura Cooper those wide
receivers good stuff mojo we appreciate
your time as always have fun this
weekend thanks for joining us all right
Maurice jones-drew NFL Network analyst
the Rams ready
color analyst as well got lost on us
yesterday and doesn't have to apologize
he's been there many many years I go
back to the first time we met him we
were in Miami and we were doing our
radio show and he showed up no one saw
no one around him no nothing he just he
just walked up I think he had like a
plaid shirt on and he just said hey I'm
uh I'm here and we're like oh okay yeah
hold on we were in a commercial break
and he just walked up on the set and
killed it he's always been very good
he's not afraid he's uh you know very
very entertaining solo good AB mojo on
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]